the fans want more so we're going to do
something we call audience ask allured
ad mm-hmm there you go
so where is Leticia Leticia can sing I
heard her on commercial break okay so
what do you want to ask Lisa so uh Kelly
so nice to meet you Lisa nice to meet
you Andy and puffy what's good so the
question I had for you is if you had to
be locked in a room with any of the real
housewives who would it be and what
would you talk about to make the time
pass Wow my goodness that's not fair
things like just left oh it could be
from any it was the brownie from any of
the French I think probably bats me but
I probably wouldn't have to discuss
anything with folks I wouldn't get a
word in edgeways because yeah yeah so
probably Bethany that's awesome well
thank you Letitia yeah we have another
question here we go
where is Brenna
[Applause]
so I actually have two questions okay
Rudy but okay the first one is do you
think that Stassi and Kristen are going
to be able to mend things well I think
fundamentally there's been a difference
between them I mean I try not to weigh
in on this too much personally because
I've always found Kristin hook difficult
to get on with myself but I think this
year as Stas has grown up they both have
grown up I have to say she's got a book
deal now Kristen and stassi's you know
getting married and she's been on the
bestseller list so they're both growing
up but I think the debye just got wider
and wider and I don't know but there's
years of history so I'm hopeful because
it's a shame to break up such a long
friendship but I don't know this season
it was very bumpy very bumpy cross yeah
all right what's the second question and
then what do you think the deal is with
Jax unfollowing everybody I cannot spill
that one because that kind of comes at
the end of the the season I'm just
trying to get you working for exactly I
can't get that away otherwise I will be
in but you know Jax his very complicated
complicated character he sounds fun that
is bad I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this